PEGI 12
welcome to battlefleet gothic the new
space RTS said in the Warhammer 40,000
universe the chaos war fleet has finally
emerged from the eye of terror ready to
invade the Imperial worlds of the Gothic
sector these are the ships that will
make the bulk of your chaos fleet in the
12th Black Crusade of Abaddon the
Despoiler chaos ships are a twisted
reflection of their Imperial Navy
counterparts their design may be older
than those of the Imperium that they are
by no means less deadly their ships are
not a sturdy nor are their weapons as
powerful
they are faster and their engagement
range longer is to the longer reach of
the last batteries the station's form
works well in synergy with these traits
trapping the enemy ships in their
ordnance while not affecting your own
Lance's astute chaos Admirals will be
able to inflict considerable damage to
the enemy fleet before they even return
fire if the gods of chaos deem you
worthy they may grant you their favor
corn Senesh zinc and Naugle each of the
kales marks give different bonuses and
new ability to your ships all along with
their crew the might of the chaos war
fleet knows no bounds thanks in no small
part to its enormous planet-killer
Abaddon's Admiral ship light of the
Gothic sector
that's while Black Crusade begins early
2016 in part of the Gothic Armada
you